jing did not abandon gon well he did but
that was only after he didn't yes it is
confusing but let's examine the biggest
myth in hunter hunter hello and welcome
to the new world review your source for
everything anime and manga my name is
liam and i come from the real life dark
continent australia but today we're here
to discuss this whole jing abandonment
myth because what would you say if i
told you that jing both did and did not
abandon gon depending entirely on how
you consumed tanta hunter well that's
true depending on whether you read the
manga or watch the anime jing freaks can
either be seen as some sort of grand
stoic hero or some sort of slimy
deadbeat daddo that's a pretty big
impression gap though and all of it
stems from a gigantic change that the
anime made from the manga that no one
ever really seems to notice so let's go
ahead and bust the biggest myth in
hunter hunter and it's all going to be
in with a quick round of gone with the
wind a very simple mini game the rules
of which are as follows a strong gust of
wind has blown gone away and it's going
to be your job to guess which of the
following locations he will land on
should you guess incorrectly then your
punishment will be to subscribe to the
new world review thus resulting in
consistent injections of hunter-based
culture administered directly into your
youtube feed and if you are correct then
you will win a thumbs up from mr gone so
which location will it be whale island
greed island or dark big island
continent make your choice now and we
shall reveal the answer in three two one
and bam it was whale island so if you
guessed incorrectly then you know the
thing to do and please do say hi in the
comments below if you are a new member
of our association welcome whale island
is important though because that's where
this whole abandonment myth spawns from
and that's kind of the anime's fault so
i've said it before i'm saying it now
and i'll say it at least one other time
in the future but the 2011 hunter hunter
anime is one of the best adaptations
i've of anything i think i've ever seen
it's almost everything one can ask for
solid animation beautifully crisp art
and for the most part incredibly
engaging pacing however like everything
in existence ever there are still
problems and weirdly enough almost all
of those problems including the myth we
are exploring here today stems from this
very first episode episode 1 of 2011
hunt hunter in many ways is quite the
disaster because a conscious decision
was made to significantly speed up the
events of the story so that gone ends up
meeting karapika and leorio by the time
the episode ends and i get why this was
done because it is a nice idea to
introduce most of your main characters
in a single city and get people
intrigued the issue is that to do this
the 2011 anime needed to take the
30-plus pages of chapter one and
condense it down to roughly five minutes
now i like quick pacing
but that's too quick and as a result a
lot of stuff needed to be cut such as
gone's flashback with kite which is very
unfortunate because that gives us the
entire reason why gone wanted to become
a hunter and it also cuts the character
of khan the fox bear that gone adopted
and raised which is sad because seeing
the adult con isn't indicated to us as
the audience that gone is capable of
keeping his promises and has matured to
the point where he's actually ready to
venture out into the world but the most
majorist of changes of all is one that
almost nobody picks up on because in the
manga just prior to leaving gon and mito
have a very very interesting discussion
one where she reveals the truth behind
the whole jing situation and she says
the following gone i'm sorry i lied to
you again jing didn't abandon you i made
him give you up to which gun replies
yeah i kind of figured that whenever you
lie you never look me in the eyes so
jing didn't abandon gong what so this is
very counter to what the 2011 anime
tells us quite polar opposites really
because in episode one as gon is packing
to leave mito very specifically reminds
gon that his father abandoned him and
when we do get to the conversation
outside their dialogue has changed
completely instead of revealing the
truth that jing did not in fact abandon
gon mito instead just makes gon promise
to come back safely and then they do a
sort of cutesy pinky promise thing that
also is not in the manga so in the space
of almost exactly five minutes the
hunter hunter anime and the hunt hunter
manga have become almost entirely
different stories in the manga gone is
looking for his father a man who was
forced to give up his son due to mito's
actions meanwhile in the anime gon is
looking for his father once again but
he's a man who dumped him on whale
island because he wanted to pursue his
own selfish goals this creates two very
very different impressions of jing one
is a legendary and almost sympathetic
hunter and the other is simply a bit of
a deadbeat dad at the very least i think
that jin could have helped this by doing
a course with the sponsor of today's
video skillshare skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
inspiring classes for creative and
curious people explore new skills
develop existing interests and get lost
in creativity recently i've done a
course in productivity for artists
because i'm always looking for new ways
to manage my time efficiently and i've
picked up quite a few handy things to
implement but skillshare is curated
specifically for learning meaning that
there are no ads and they're always
launching new premium classes so you can
stay focused and follow wherever your
creativity takes you skillshare offers
membership with meaning connect with the
support of fellow creatives and enter a
community of encouragement communication
and of course inspiration last the first
1 000 of my subscribers to click the
link in the description will get a one
month free trial skillshare so that you
can start exploring your creativity
today but now back to allegedly deadbeat
dance and now before we all start going
ra
anime ra ra hashtag justice for jing
rah-rah this isn't a change that was
made for a trivial reason there are
changes in the 2011 anime that i do
think legitimately hurt the series like
the aforementioned omission of the kite
flashback however this is a change that
i think was quite carefully considered
and to put it quite simply the change
was made to reflect the modern day jing
what do i mean by that well as i've said
many times on this channel what hunter
hunter started out as and what it became
are two entirely different products the
first chapter of hunter hunter is about
as standard of a shonen series as you
can get young boy with latent desire and
big dreams gets given final push to go
on grand journey and with that one
sentence i've just described probably
every shonen in existence it's very well
written but honestly there's nothing too
special about the first chapter of
hunter hunter however as part of that
stock standard shonen formula jing makes
up a very specific piece in that puzzle
interestingly he's sort of like a blend
between the mentor and the goal and a
rough equivalent i would have for this
is shanks from one piece you know
luffy's goal is to become a great pirate
at which point he will return shanks's
hat gone is and i use these words quite
liberally on a similarly set up journey
he wants to find his father and return
his hunter's license a father who in
chapter one is almost a paragon of
morality and just general amazingness
you know kite practically verbally jerks
jing off in this chapter just gushing
about how amazing he is and even mito
has to admit that the one and only bad
thing that jing has ever done in this
world was actually kind of her fault so
jing is very much set up to be our
standard wise and powerful shonen mentor
guy now regardless of any changes that
were made in the anime that's well
that's not quite what jing turned out to
be as hunter hunter evolved over the
years so did it saw the yoshihiro
tagashi as did the characters of the
series and arguably even the overall
genre of hunter hunter i would honestly
describe it as more of a seinen story
these days and the character who almost
certainly changed the most over this
time was jing by the time jing actually
made a non-flashback appearance in the
story we had gone through some radical
waves of evolution york new city had
brought us a much darker and more
complex world which greed island and the
chimera antarctic built and expanded on
even more at this stage tagashi was no
longer interested in guiding hunter
hunter down the shonen pathway and very
much like the evolution of his ant
characters the series had become
completely unrecognizable from its
original incarnation and there was no
room for this idealistic and nyon
perfect jing freaks that was presented
in chapter one instead the antithesis
was brought before us jing is portrayed
as a sloppy selfish and pretty seriously
despised figure within the hunter
association and this could not be
further from the almost heroic
description from kite in chapter 1 or
even the general admiration expressed by
satots at the end of the hunter exam
it's a complete subversion of
expectation and not one that was planned
from the beginning but a subversion that
had naturally developed alongside
togashi so much so that when you look
back on the early days of hunter hunter
in general seeing or hearing anything of
jing is like referring to an entirely
different character now when the 2011
anime began they had the advantage of
knowing what hunter hunt would become
unlike tagashi drawing the manga they
had a road map clearly marked with all
the crazy left and yes even sometimes
right turns so far right that they
became left which then went so far left
that they became right and it all just
went in a big hunter hunter circley
thing so while the first episode wasn't
strictly speaking a faithful adaptation
with this whole jing business it does
actually reflect the greater story and
world far more accurately regardless of
where he started out jing ended up being
a bit of a junk father it wasn't a job
that was ever suited to him and whilst
he did have some care for and even
impart some gems onto gone they really
don't have that solid familial bond you
know the kind that gone has with mito
and that's another reason why this
change was made because it's not just
about reflecting modern day jing but
about reflecting mito in chapter one she
almost comes off as a bit of a villain
effectively admitting that she is the
reason why gon doesn't know his father
and the last piece of dialogue we have
of her is apologizing profusely which
needs gone's forgiveness it's a nice
dramatic moment but the 2011 anime
instead chose to enhance their bond
rather than break it down instead of
descending into this drama gon and mito
have a solid pinky promised thing and
the last thing they save each other are
smiling faces as an audience we are left
with no doubt at all concerning this
relationship whereas in the manga we're
kind of like you know mito that was kind
of a dick move and gone is a big man boy
for forgiving you because that's what
shonen heroes do they forgive people for
things and this also has an effect on
gohan's character as well the whole line
where he states that he knew meeto was
lying in the manga makes him out to be
an extremely emotionally intelligent
young man someone who may not have all
of the book smarts but he clearly
understands the world around him on a
very primal level and that's the sort of
gone that we see a lot of during the
hunter exam arc and then
never again as gone continues in hunter
hunter his flaws become a lot more
apparent and a big crux of the character
is him not understanding the feelings of
those around him the best example of
that being of course killer past the
zeldic family arc gone is completely
oblivious to killer's emotions and it
just doesn't quite gel with the
character that we're given in chapter
one so in that way the 2011 anime gone
is a bit more consistent however this is
far from a perfect seamless change and
it does definitely make some things a
bit more difficult to reconcile for
example a lot of people often question
why gon is so determined to find jing or
why he doesn't resent his father for
leaving him and the initial offering of
the manga sums all of that up quite
nicely gone isn't capable of resenting
his father because it wasn't jing's
fault that he had to leave once again it
was technically mito's fault and sure
she obviously had gone's best interest
at heart but that doesn't change the
action itself plus with a lifetime of
having his father forcibly removed from
his life all of a sudden it does make a
lot of sense to want to go and find him
although that aspect is far more
prevalently pushed by the kite flashback
so it's a tricky issue to adjudicate
because both parts have their advantages
and their pitfalls what the manga did
was a stock standard cohesive setup
where gone's motivations make 100 solid
sense and it's very easy to embark on
that journey however what the anime did
was more accurate to what the story was
going to become and i do think it does a
better job of making the realities of
the world itself a little bit more
cohesive as well as highlighting the
bond between gonomito so as radical of a
change as it is i do think it was
probably the right decision to change
this one massive conversation and sure
you can argue that hey this isn't fair
on jing he gets a pretty bad rap for the
whole child abandonment thing but that
is the man that togashi eventually chose
to create all this change really does is
remove that initial illusion and it
gives the anime audience a much more
accurate sense of what to expect from
jing because this world has no heroes
and whatever jing was meant to be when
togashi began the series has no place in
what it became but that still does leave
us with the rather annoying question of
did jing abandon gone because
canonically i guess no no he didn't i
think i mean this is one of the big
problems with a writing style like
togashi's because his naturally
developing garden doesn't necessarily
reflect the seeds that he used and i did
say at the beginning of this video that
the answer to this question depends
entirely on which medium you consumed in
hunter hunter but it's actually more
complicated than even that even if we
restrict our focus to the manga alone
there are two very different stories
being told here and sometimes you simply
can't take what togashi was setting up
in the early days as set in stone gospel
in fact you can't really take anything
as set in stone because tagashi is a man
whose mind will never settle he just
keeps moving from idea to idea to idea
and he's much more interested in playing
out those scenarios than he is in
strictly enforcing the canon of the
world which is fine by the way i mean
i'd probably give a lot of other authors
a pretty hard time about that kind of
thing but in togashi's case it works
much more in favor of the series than it
does against it but ultimately did jing
abandon gone well no no he didn't but
also yes yes he did i mean pretty much
no but also mostly yes and mostly yes is
also the answer to our question of
whether or not you would like another
video because there's always more to
learn explore and experience with this
wonderful series so i look forward to
seeing you there